all right charlie
charlie where'd you grow up where are
you from originally albuquerque new
mexico albuquerque yeah and tell me
about your family yeah mom and dad my
mom and dad my dad died about two years
ago and my mom
she's out in new mexico with her son my
brother
yeah how was how would you describe your
childhood
it was crazy i mean all the drugs and
sexual harassment to
the grand theft auto
and
everything
so you started getting in trouble early
yeah since i was 12 years old well at
six i remember taking
both of my dad's guns in the closet and
he already knew it was me
and i was he was already telling me you
sold it huh
and
yeah that's when i started getting in
trouble so
you're you're
the black sheep of the family yeah as
you can see
um why do you think that was was there
any abuse in your childhood or just it's
just the way you're wired i think it was
more of a favorite of my brother and
then me
um because my brother was the oldest so
he's the first baby
and
so and he was a good child i was a bad
child
you started with drugs early yeah
the crystal meth
what age is that at 12. 12. yeah
who introduced you to crystal method 12.
um the friends my ex-boyfriend um i was
with him for about four years and he was
a little older than me
and he used to beat on me too
and we used to get high
we used to just you know
steal a lot of stuff and not do good
hmm did you finish high school no i
haven't finished high school how far did
you go in school uh seventh grade
after seventh grade you yeah you bailed
and i
i was like i'm out
where'd you go at um
i assumed you left your first i was just
yeah i came out here after my dad died
and when i came out here i became
homeless how old are you now i'm 22.
yeah
i was staying on skid row at first
that's where i first was
staying in the tents
and seeing how
it was like and it was just crazy
um how long were you down here
um foot in color well in skate row it's
cute bro i was there for three or four
months just messing up i was looking
really bad i mean
i barely started putting on weight have
you been supporting yourself however i'm
supporting myself i did survival sex
here and there where you sleep with a
guy and you just get a place to sleep
for the night or food you know
also just begging for money i guess
call it that and
my gr i got gr food stamps
so now you are staying where
now i got a shelter i'm staying in a
shelter so um
it's better for you yeah
get my life together i start my new job
monday
wow you're a shelter and you have a job
yeah good for you
so for all the people who you know
are just thinking they can't do it they
really can it's just all your mindset
and your mental what do you think has
helped you the most not that you're over
the hump but you're going the right
direction yeah so getting there
what's what's helped you
uh just thinking about my dad and just
looking at everything
like out you see out on the streets and
just i don't want to be like that you
know
i want to do good and do better
for myself and for the community too not
just
good for you what's your relationship
like with your
mom and your brother it's not good i'm
not close to them at all like that
i remember my mom was an alcoholic she
told me when i was about eight years old
get the hell out of my house i don't
want you no more because i didn't get a
beer out the damn refrigerator
yeah so i've been through a lot
do you have any friends
friends no acquaintances yeah yeah
street
street friends yeah
but they're not no good so i'm trying to
like fall back from them you know
get away from all the bad influences
what was your favorite memory as a child
as a child my favorite memory
being on my dad's back and him almost
dropping me
when we was on where we had a little hot
tub set up a deck we had a deck and
everything and he was climbing up the
deck and i was on his back and he almost
dropped me
what are you
lonely now it means he said lonely yeah
i'm hella lonely i cry and i stress out
and sometimes i get mad just blaming my
dad like why you gotta leave me why you
gotta leave me you know you're close to
your dad yeah that is a girl
what do you worry about now what do you
what do you what i worry about now is
staying off these streets and not losing
my job and you know
just i want to stay clean
i barely got clean about a week ago we
did yeah so you haven't used for a week
yeah for a whole week and it's hard it's
hard it's really hard
but you just got to find productive
stuff to help you through it you know
staying dizzy you don't have kids no no
kids
keep it that way for a while you're
right
do you have any plans or goals
plans yes i actually came out here to do
music and
own my own business construction and
then helping the people off the streets
who can and cannot help themselves
how do you feel your time on the streets
has affected you how has it changed
i learned a lot i learned what and what
not to do or stay out on these streets
it's hard for a female right yeah way
harder
like way harder and guys don't realize
that they think we have it easy hill no
what kind of stuff happens to a girl
you could get raped you could um end up
wanting to sell your own self you could
get forced to style yourself so you're
pressured into it yeah they're tricked
into it are tricked into a yup they try
to do that so many times to me but
i've always made it
i've always been smarter than the game
they play
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
young life in my young life
go to school
and listen to your damn parents because
when you're out on the streets doing
drugs you're gonna wish you wish you did
you know
your
what do you think your the biggest
problem was for you in terms of doing
that was was it
losing your dad or was it just the way
your mom treated you or acting
from the past it was the way my mom i
never had my mom and me just directs the
sexual harassment and stuff really got
to me that's sexual abuse yeah yes abuse
yeah there you go sexual abuse from who
um
my own brother
and his friends
and
maybe when i was about six seven years
old
and to this day i asked my brother and i
asked his friends and
they still want to deny and not give me
an answer and one of them understood
that they're young they're a kid
but still you're older than me you're 15
14 you know i was like
seven eight years old
but
recently when i got heavy into the drugs
when i started shooting up and stuff
as i used to do needles it was after my
dad died that's when i really started
hardly messing up
yeah but it's nice that you
have the desire to straighten out your
life
yeah
i want to do it for myself and i want to
do it for my dad
because he left me 45 000 and i got
nothing to show for it you burned it all
yeah all on drugs on helping other
people and
you know just
burning it all off that's the one thing
i see from all these interviews i've
done is no one knows how to handle money
they have money in their pocket they
burn it
i feel
now i'm gonna start being careful my
money yeah
it's a great lesson to learn right
that's your most important lesson you've
learned yeah
that's definitely yeah it's a good
lesson for everybody
all right charlie well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you thank
you wish you the best of luck you too
stay on track
you